In today's video we are taking a look at how you can safely make your own breakaway glass at home
Guys we love this studio. It has been our home for a really long time
But that said it's a bit time for an update
So we're going to be adding a few new things throughout the next coming videos, but before we get started on our project today
Let's start with a fresh coat of paint
Alright guys, we have started redecorating the studio as you can see we're not done yet
But don't panic it is gonna be changing over the next few videos and the idea right now is to get some decorations in place
So for the first decoration that I think that I want now we have been working on building a new work bench
Which is going to be fantastic, we're gonna have a few new really useful things
But I think we need an in case of emergency box. Now what we put in this will have to decide later
But for now if we have an in case of emergency break blast box
We don't necessarily want actual broken glass all around the studio
so there are a few different ways that you can make safe breakaway glass or film or
theater anything like that in modern film work one of the most common forms of breakaway glass is actually
smashed glass or different types of breakaway plastic now
That's not how they used to do it
It used to actually just be a type of sugar glass
Now sugar glass has the tendency of turning yellow if you try and harden it
So what we actually want to try today is sugar glass and then compare it with
Isomalt sugar glass has the tendency of having a bit of a yellow tint as it
Caramelizes when it gets to the hard crack stage, so it doesn't look perfectly clear now
Isomalt is a little bit different isomalt tends to melt at a slightly lower temperature and ends up crystal clear
So that's what we're gonna try today along with some sugar glass
See we can actually get that in our shadow box to make our own break in case of emergency box. Here's the basic idea
We have got a shadow box. We've got some isomalt
We've got some sugar and we've got a few ideas on how we can turn this into some glass that we can break safely in
The studio so for our first few steps here, we're gonna go ahead and take our isomalt
we're gonna take our sugar and we're gonna get them melting on the stove while that's going we're gonna take apart our shadow box and
Get rid of the actual glass get it ready for our sugar glass
So when it comes to making breakaway glass at home
It's actually pretty simple if you have sugar and you have a candy thermometer, then it's really really easy
We'll go ahead and go over measurements and a cup of minutes
But if you can heat this sugar up to the hard crack stage and then pour it smooth
You shouldn't have any problems. As I said before though. It will be caramelized
You will have a slight discoloration which is why we're going to try the ice malt as well
So we're gonna go ahead and preheat our oven
Preheat the stove and get this going now because I know that the sugar is going to be discolored
I'm not even going to bother trying to put that into our breakaway box today
So I will be making a smaller sheet with our sugar glass and then we have a larger sheet
That's actually smoother with no bent edges for our isomalt. So we're not gonna have any problems with warping for the isomalt
I'm also aware that my shadow box has a piece of glass that is ten by twenty inches and this
Cookie sheet is a little bit larger than that. So I shouldn't have any problems there right now
I'm just testing to see how much sugar I actually am going to be needing to make now
This is two cups of water that I've just poured into the the pan for our sugar glass
It's not quite coating it thick enough to make me happy
So I think we're gonna double this recipe might be a thicker pane that might not use all of it
But that way I'd rather have more than less. So for your basic sugar recipe this is gonna be very simple
This is gonna be four cups of sugar a cup and a half of water and then two 2/3 cups of corn syrup
We're gonna go ahead and stir this on a low heat until it's fully
Dissolved and then we'll turn that up to a medium heat and we're gonna go ahead and let this
Heat up until it hits hard crack stage and then we'll remove it from the heat and pour it directly into our mold
you guys I have no idea if I got enough ice and mom you don't really need to use a lot of water for the
Isomalt, so let's just see how this
look
So I actually think this is going to be a perfect amount of isomalt
So one bag of kitchen alchemy, this is 2.2 pounds or 36 ounces of isomalt
I think that's going to be pretty perfect for our 10 by 20 inch pane of glass that we need
However, I am going to use both bags. I did buy two bags of isomalt
I'm gonna melt it all but I'm not going to pour it all at the same time
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna have it all melt down on the stove. The oven will be preheated to
275 degrees Fahrenheit we'll go ahead and just let all of the bubble sort of rise
To make it really really clear and then after that we'll go ahead and pour two separate sheets when melting isomalt
Everyone does things a little bit differently
some people say you want to add enough water for it to be the
Consistency of what's and some people say you don't even need to add any at all
I like to add just a little bit to my pot to make sure that nothing's burning on the bottom
But then I just keep it at a low heat until it's all melted
then pop it into the oven to make sure that we had all of those bubbles rising to the surface the main thing you really
Want to make sure of when you're working with icing up is that all of your equipment is very very clean?
Distilled water is preferred
I have found that I've been able to get some very very nice results without it
But do make sure you have a very clean pot
Very clean spatula and make sure not to cross contaminate it with your sugar if you're melting them at the same time
We're gonna go ahead and keep a simmer for our sugar while our isomalt is melting the ice melts gonna be much slower
It's gonna be much calmer. Well this hits a hard crack stage. This is simply just gonna melt down
Until it's ready to go in the oven
so I would say we've probably got about 10 minutes where I can actually leave these kind of let them melt as they go so
Well, they're melting on the stove. I'm going to go ahead and get started on the shadowbox itself
So to begin with this is a shadowbox. These can be found at most craft stores framing stores things like that
Normally what they're used for is for pinning or placing little mementos that might be thicker that you might put in a normal frame
So you can see that we've got a pretty good depth here on this one. So it should give us a really nice sort of
Emergency box we can put any sort of emergency supplies in here that we might need
So first things first, we don't need the real glass. So let's take that
Reowww glass removed
Our isomalt is not done melting
However, our sugar has hit it's hard crack stage and you can see it's actually already got that sort of a yellow tint
It's pretty much ready to pour. I want to do get my tray ready for it now
Well, I'm not too worried about it sticking to my non-stick pan
I am going to add a very thin layer of cooking oil it will
Fog up the glass just a little bit but less chance of it breaking when I try and pull it out later
You can see that there's obviously going to be a color change. That's not going to look like regular glass
It's still going to be a nice safe breakaway glass
But not the color we're going for so we're going to show you the difference
So I'm going to go ahead and pour this now and hope it cools and comes out without breaking. Let's see
That is about
350 degrees Fahrenheit right now. So just tipping this tray. I'd be super careful
I'm gonna take this and we're just gonna dip the bottom to cool it down just enough so that it does stop cooking
It'll still be heated, but it won't be cooking anymore
Be very careful if you do this because this steam rising is hot enough to burn you
There we go, but you can see that our bubbles have all calmed down
So now what we're gonna do is we're gonna pop this in the oven for about 15 minutes again
Just to get these bubbles to rise to the surface so that women report we get a nice clear glass look
Yes, oh now I do wish I have my audio on because I'm like dancing over here
This is looking super good the surface has a really interesting texture kind of looks like the surface of the Moon guys
I still made again because I needed a second pair of hands and he has hands
But we have got our sugar glass
we have got our isomalt glass and we want to try and get these out of the pans and
I'm very worried that with just one set of hands. The bending is gonna probably break them. So here's the plan
I'm gonna try and tip them out once we've got them out
We will need to cut one down to size and the way you do that is with a very very hot knife
We've got our knives heating up on the stove. Yeah this one it's already actually can already see. Yes it delaminates at the edges
It's just beautiful, which is exactly what we were going for
So I think well
What we can do is we if we put the cardboard over it
And flip it and we can just gently press from the back on the metal plate. I think it will all release
All right. We give it a try. We give it a try
I've never actually seen anybody try and make sheet isomalt before glass or sugar glass
Yes, but I don't think I needed to do any pouring not just yeah pop right out there. Oh
My gosh, oh that's gonna taste like cooking spray. Oh
It tastes great. This turned out so much better than we are expecting. Yes, because it is sugar glass. Yes
It does caramelize it does turn, you know a little bit yellow
But this is so much smoother than we were expecting. You can even see the logo of harvest, right?
So from our freeze dry pan, you can see it right there
So very very hot knife
We've had it just boiling on the stove
But then I'm drying it so that it won't it won't gum up our our sugar glass now
I know that supposedly this works with isomalt. I do not know if it works with sugar glass quite the same so far
I'm gonna say no, but we're still gonna try because even regular glass you can score and break
All right. Yep thousand-degree knife challenge go for it
Aha hey that looks like it did something Wow, yeah that was much much more efficient
Exactly those look like that. I came off nice exactly how you do it. I just want it to be known
I don't know if it was caught on camera. She literally just said hit me in the head. It's fine. I got it
Just go for it. All right
Yeah
Action star we're gonna clean up and then we're gonna move on to our isomalt
All right. So sugar glass it does work. You can make amazing breakaway panels with it
The isomalt is the one that's very clear. This is the one I'm excited about
This is the one that I want to put into our emergency kit box to put on the wall
So see if we get it to come out just as easily as the sugar glass. Did I'm gonna flip towards you. Okay ready? Oh,
Sure, that's out that sounded like a freak though. That sounds like correct, please don't be broken. Please don't be broken
Yes, amazing sheet, I think that's gonna be okay and again there's this bit of cloudiness from the oil
So I think we're gonna try and hit it with the torch again
see if we can clean it up just a little bit and then we're gonna cut it down to size and get it into our
emergency kit
We've got it in place it's not perfectly smooth
So I'm gonna use our smaller torch see if we can clean that up a little bit and then we're gonna get some writing on
It mess happening along the side here. There we go
Alright guys
We've got it in case of emergency we are set
But I'll show you put in the studio
Guys, that's not all we've always got more for you to see that box up at the top will take you to our latest video
In that box the bottom is what YouTube thinks you should be watching next hit this bomb in the middle to subscribe to the club
So you never miss out on the fun. Don't forget to ring that Bell and we'll see in the next one. Talk to you then